as you mentioned mainstream and Fringe
there seems to be a tension here and I
wonder what your philosophy is on it
because there's mainstream ideas and
there's Fringe ideas uh you look at lab
League Theory uh for this virus that
could be other things we can discuss
where
there's a mainstream narrative well if
you just look at the percent
of the population
or the population with platforms what
they say and then uh what is a small
percentage uh in opposition to that and
what is Wikipedia's responsibility to
accurately represent both the mainstream
and The Fringe do you think well I mean
I I think we we have to try to do our
best to to recognize both but also to
appropriately contextualize and so this
can be quite hard particularly when
emotions are high that's just a fact
about human beings
um I'll give a simpler example because
there's not a lot of emotion around it
like our entry on the moon doesn't say
some say the moon's made of rocks some
say cheese you know who knows that kind
of false neutrality is not what we want
to get to like that doesn't make any
sense but that one's easy like we all
understand
um I think there is a Wikipedia entry
called something like the moon is made
of cheese where it talks about this is a
common sort of joke or or thing that
children say or that people tell to
children or whatever you know it's just
a thing it's everybody's heard Moon's
made of cheese
um but
nobody thinks wow like Wikipedia is so
one-sided it doesn't even acknowledge
the cheese Theory
um I say the same thing about Flat Earth
you know again it's exactly what I'm
looking up right now very little
controversy uh we will have an entry
about Flat Earth theory theorizing
people
um my personal view is most the people
who claim to be flat earthers are just
having a laugh trolling and more power
to them have some fun but uh let's not
be you know ridiculous
but of course for mostly human history
people believe that the Earth is flat so
the article I'm looking at is actually
kind of focusing on this history Flat
Earth is an archaic in scientifically
disproven conception of the Earth's
shape as a plane or disc many ancient
cultures subscribed to a flat Earth
cosmography with pretty cool pictures of
what a flat Earth would look like
with dragon is that Dragon No Angels on
the on the edge
there's a lot of controversy about that
what is in the edge is it the wall is it
Angels the dragons is there a dome and
how can you fly from
uh South Africa to Perth because on a
flat Earth view that's really too far
for any plane to make it what I want to
know it's all spread out what I want to
know is what's on the other side Jimmy
what's on the other side that's what all
of us want to know yeah
um
so there's some I presume there's
probably a small section about the
conspiracy theory of Flat Earth because
I think there's a sizeable percent of
the population who at least will say
they believe in a flat Earth yeah I I
think it is a movement
um that just says that the mainstream
narrative
to have distrust and skepticism about
the mainstream narrative which to a very
small degree is probably a very
productive thing to do it's part of the
scientific process but you can get a
little silly and ridiculous with it yeah
uh I mean yeah it it it's exactly right
and so
um you know I I think I find on on many
many cases and of course I like anybody
else might quibble about this or that in
any Wikipedia article but in general I
think there is a pretty good
um sort of willingness and indeed
eagerness to say oh let's let's fairly
represent all of the meaningfully
important sides so there's still a lot
to unpack in that right so meaningfully
important so you know uh people who
um
are raising questions about the efficacy
of masks okay that's actually a
reasonable thing to have a discussion
about and hopefully we should treat that
as a as a fair conversation to have and
actually address which authorities have
said what and so on and so forth
um and then you know there are other
cases where it's not meaningful
opposition you know like you just
wouldn't say if I I mean I
I doubt if the main article Moon
it may mention
cheese probably not even because it's
not credible and it's not even meant to
be serious by anyone or the article on
the Earth
certainly won't have a paragraph that
says well most scientists think it's
round but
certain people think flat like that's
just a silly thing to put in that
article you would want to sort of
address you know that's an interesting
cultural phenomenon you want to put it
somewhere
um so this you know this goes into uh
all kinds of things about politics you
want to be really careful really
thoughtful about not getting caught up
in the anger of our times and really
recognize yes I I always thought
I remember being really kind of proud of
the us at the time when it was uh McCain
was running against Obama because I
thought oh I've got plenty of
disagreements with both of them but they
both seem like thoughtful and
interesting people who I would have
different disagreements with but I
always felt like yeah like that that's
good now we can have a debate now we can
have an interesting debate and it isn't
just sort of people slamming each other
personal attacks and so forth
and you're saying Wikipedia has also
represented that
I hope so yeah and I think so in in the
main obviously you can always find a
debate that went horribly wrong because
there's humans involved